[Music]
shucks bottle has cursed us or dentists
I will have my revenge it's time to hunt
a pirate
[Music]
just borrow
[Music]
ready pg-13 tickets available now
pirates had infected the seas for
generations
so I felt eliminate them all
let's borrow crushed me I will have my
revenge
you sure you Jack Sparrow
first your pants a great planet does not
require such intricacies
Karina is the only one who can help us
I'm not looking for trouble was a
horrible lazily
I'm a woman of science I choose not to
believe in first do you not see what's
behind us
Oh monkey
I hope irises stupid
there's no contain scenes that may be
too intense for younger viewers pirates
had infected the Seas for generations so
I filed will eliminate them all then
there was this boy that's borrowed I
will have my revenge Nami is that coming
straight for you jack
pirate's life
there's nowhere to hide
[Music]
rated pg-13
we wanted to make this pirates of the
carribean I'm really special and really
fresh so we got two new directors
yokomen Espen who are Academy nominated
filmmakers reinvigorate the franchise
with something we've never seen before
there are new characters are gonna bring
any flavor and a different dimension to
one of the most powerful franchises
full-time when we heard there were
planning on making and other pirates we
chased it we wanted it to feel like the
right be found and scary and emotional
and that means huge action pieces
we have thousands of extras huge builds
and epic shots with fantastic locations
this film is exciting there's something
huge happening every day so it has an
energy and a force behind it but I've
never really experienced before not only
is it huge in scope but we're dealing
with iconic characters and iconic ships
and elements I felt there was some sense
of magic walking off to the upsets scene
the craftsmanship in the detail it's
very easy to lose yourself and to feel
like you are in another world
the men tell no tales
the dad taking see mr. shivers
for its life
rated pg-13
[Applause]
[Music]
when I hear the trumpet sound
I'm on a rise well out of the ground
ain't no grave can hold my body down dad
asaji crisper
I see a band
and coming at
ain't no grain
[Applause]
pirates life there ain't no brain hello
my buddy in the dad didn't come back
such a bright girl
[Applause]
their men tell no tales
[Music]
[Music]
you believe in virus of course and you
look
you get the view that the audience gifts
[Music]
even ghost stories you're in one the
Pirates franchise it's wonderful
characters caught up in this magical
fantastic world
we took a movie about a ride in a movie
that's about pirates and the combination
of those two is just captured
everybody's imagination and beginning
your success welcome to the Caribbean
that the fan base for Pirates of the
Caribbean has become massive Odie and
Johnny as Jack Sparrow I just think he's
extraordinary he's created this
fantastic character who became kind of
an icon that everybody loves
[Music]
we have such fond memories of the first
three then it's just gone making a meal
when you watch the films you get this
feeling this sensation that anything can
happen
janice buttrum can you notice Byron his
new Peretz movie has new characters are
gonna bring a new flavor and a different
dimension to one of the most powerful
franchises of all time
dad I've taken
this movie is so fresh so different so
scary it's a whole reinvention of a
pirate's me
sar its life
[Music]
[Music]
pirates had infected the seas for
generations
so I vowed Polly named mo
and then there was this boy jetsparrow
follow him in he took everything from me
Rache
[Applause]
the dad I've taken see you girl I've
heard stories the mighty Spanish captain
was son to be killed thousands of men no
no no no men no no pirates pirates I
once knew is Spaniard in something in
Spanish
he's coming future
where's your [ __ ] the crew
your pants Jackie I'm so sorry we're
still talking there's no word hide
find spiral for me
from this moment on we ought to be
allies
considering where your left hand is
except where more than that
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
looking for trouble horrible anal Dean
- time for what you did to me
mmmm on Shope you're looking for jackets
I'm going to swim for it Karina stop
this oh no no no that's all right this
has gone far enough
no it has not I saw our ankles you just
send a lot more if you can't be hiked
holeshot
[Music]
and the robot look everybody drop your
weapons yeah give me all your cash in
the camera
I've been expecting you for hours my
name is Captain Jack Sparrow and I would
like to swim to you jump in you
[Music]
who owns rap survived great
does the sore make my bum look big
naughty
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
on you all together today is name is you
almost captured Captain Jack Sparrow
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
jealous patro Devo Spirent Ivany by name
fine spiral for me I'm really a method
from collapse and tell him
dan goes straight would you see him
please
[Music]
[Music]